اوضح الامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
جاسم محمد البديوي انا اللقاء الذي جمع
وزراء الخارجيه لدول الخليج بحث فيه
الاطراف عده مواضيع كالعلاقه مع ايران
والتعاون العسكري وامن الممرات المائيه
بالاضافه الى التعاون الثنائي الخليجي
الامريكي في تجاره الامن السيبراني وضماني
امدادات الطاقه
فهنالك العديد من المواضيع هنالك مواضيع
المتعلقه بورش العمل المتعدده التي تربطنا
بالولايات المتحده والتي تتعلق
بموضوع الممرات المائيه التعاون العسكري
العلاقات مع ايران
والاخرى المتعلقه بالتعاون الثنائي
الخليجي الامريكي مثل التجاره مثل
الامن السيبراني والممرات المائيه ضمان
امدادات الطاقه كان واضح
الرساله التي نقلها لنا السيد بلينكن في
اكثر من مناسبه في مداخلاته العديده
بالتزام الولايات المتحده بامن واستقرار
منطقه الخليج
وشدد الامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
جاسم محمد البديوي على ان الدول المجلس
تحظى بعلاقات مميزه وشركات استراتيجيه مع
واشنطن وهي حقيقه وحاضره
الامريكيه الخليجيه في امن واستقرار منطقه
الخليج شراكه حقيقيه
شراكه مثبوته وواقعيه وحاضره هنالك تواجد
امريكي كبير عسكري في كافه منطقه الخليج
هنالك رسائل عديده ينقلها لنا الجانب
الامريكي بالتزامه بامن واستقرار منطقه
الخليج هنالك تعاون عسكري رفيع المستوى ما
بين كافه الدول الست والولايات المتحده في
الشرق العسكري
الولايات المتحده اثبتت بالسابق انها شريك
فعال
وعملي مع دول مجلس التعاون ودول مجلس
التعاون ايضا اثبتت نفس الشيء للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
كان ايضا جزء كبير من حديثنا حول هذا
الموضوع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات